that
for
[Music]
so we know we know this this training
right okay and a lot of times we think
we're relaxed but do I look
relaxed no I don't not down
here then right arms there's tension in
my body you might loosen up here there's
tension in my body okay but I don't need
that tension in my okay and what I'm
going to do is the same thing I'm doing
here when he pushes at at me and his
energy is going through me I'm not
bracing on it you understand his energy
is going through me so his
mouth I'm going to let it go through my
hand
my hand is going to penetrate the Target
and
eventually it just penetrates enough
that the elasticity of his body is going
to go that way which is exactly what
happens here well same exactly okay but
I if I'm
tense it doesn't work and if I'm tense
even though you can hurt people that way
but it doesn't doesn't doesn't do the
same thing okay so I'm very relaxed and
I just put my my fist through him until
that elasticity comes out
okay okay same exact thing
here I don't want to go here and then
[Music]
Flex as you watch and I don't know what
angle you
need he starts to fall this way you see
because my body is looking for the path
of Le
resistance and instead I don't want him
to
fall this
[Music]
way it's just going to go through
him he falls down
he falls that
way very
tense it barely
works and R through
hand so I feel his I feel his mask just
like YouTube but when I feel it I
release just like I feel his mask here
but when I do I release I don't flex and
fight it and generate the opposition you
see I release the same thing as I'm
going through everything I release
release release
release e
that release has to
happen all the way down to my
feet and the more that you feel it and
the more desire you have that is that
same tension okay
so as you smell the
throw you got to no no no no no this
goes into
him in the same way that right now he's
passing through me as he passes through
me I must be going into him you see
provable
here so
resist tempation to flex
be
loose loose all the way
down so that your hand is heavy your
hand is
heavy but release just like when
you it's heavy
heavy but Loose like my fist is
loose it'll do
it it'll do it
okay e
okay so again tension is not shape
they're different so I don't have to
lose all shape to lose
tension keep my
shape without the tension no tension
it
also tension is not uh does not have
anything to do with the
rate okay but you can still do this
exactly like
that and kind of do it exactly the
same a little quicker doesn't have
anything to do okay tension is about
your cyc
reaction to their M
okay I don't know if it shows up
but you get what I'm saying
like it looks like this
Sean you see it like this and then you
come this is all external you see
and then
you kind of flexure at the end
or tension is shape is still
there then you
go it's
this we we have a form that we want but
you you know what I mean so but all
you're doing is really just a linear
motion that has some downward at the end
do you get what I'm saying so you could
just do the same things this
way do you guys understand I I don't you
don't need that
b try and see what
happens e